APARNA: All right,
can we get started?
Great.
Good afternoon, and
welcome to IO 313.
There are a lot of amazing
product announcements
this morning.
And hopefully you noticed that
committed use discounts can
be used with Container Engine.
And now you can use
Spanner and PostgreSQL also
in your applications
with Container Engine.
There were not a lot of
Container Engine related
announcements, and that's
what this talk is for.
We're going to be
talking about some
of the latest features
that are coming up
in our next release, which
is due in early April.
So some of this material is
roadmap and subject to change
but we're excited to share
with you a preview of some
of the coolest features
that are upcoming
So one of the highlights
of working in technology,
is when you're
building a product that
is used by other
products that you love.
And that's been the case
for me with Philips Hue.
Kelsey and I, of course, work on
Kubernetes and Container Engine
here at Google, but we
are delighted to be joined
by George Yianni, who is
an inventor of Philips Hue
lighting, this is IoT
connected lighting.
I've been working with George
for the last two years,
and in close
collaboration with Google,
but even before that I had
bought Philips Hue lights,
and I have them installed
in both my living room,
as well as my kids' bedroom.
And they love the colorful
lights at night, and especially
on holidays like Halloween.
And now, knowing that
Philips Hue light is powered
by Google Container Engine, a
product that I helped build,
makes mommy very cool.
So it's not just
Philips though, you
might be surprised by how
often you are using Kubernetes.
I'd like to do a quick
show of hands here.
How many of you have recently
played a hit mobile game,
or shopped at one of the
world's largest retailers,
or followed breaking news,
or attended a concert?
And then I put the last one
in here for the workaholics
amongst us, how many of you
have filed expenses recently?
Anyone who hasn't
done any of these?
I think those people have
been busy making contributions
to the Kubernetes
open source codebase,
and they haven't
done any of these.
But as you can guess,
all of these services
are running on Kubernetes today.
And that's just us that's
just a small sampling.
So you might ask,
why is this the case?
I think there are three reasons.
Number one is speed.
And here, I'm talking about
developer productivity.
These are quotes from
some of our users.
They've moved from commit
to production in minutes,
and they do that 20
to 50 times a day.
That's number one.
Number two is scalability.
And here, it's really
efficient scale out.
So Pokemon Go the fastest
app to $1 billion,
and Kubernetes was behind
the scaling of that app.
Also Black Friday
demand, Home Depot
talked about it in yesterday's
keynote, also powered
by Kubernetes.
And what tends to happen is that
then becomes the new standard.
When a technology
becomes this commonplace,
everyone expects
all applications
to be able to meet this
type of scalability,
and this type of
development speed.
And last but not
least, it's open.
So you can use
Kubernetes anywhere,
whether it's on Google's
cloud, or it's on your premise.
And Walmart is a very
nice example of that.
Walmart are using Kubernetes in
their logistics warehouses, 200
of these warehouses.
These are small, IT closets,
almost, with VMware on them
and they're running
Kubernetes on that.
And of course,
there are many that
are using it on Google
Cloud, as well as on AWS.
So that flexibility is something
that hopefully many of you
value.
But there's nothing
better than hearing
about an actual deployment
from an actual user.
What's it like to use
Kubernetes on Google's cloud?
Is it easy, is it
secure, is it reliable?
So for that, I'd like
to, without further ado,
welcome George Yianni
to come up on the stage
and talk about Philips Hue
and how they're using GKE.
GEORGE: Thank you
very much, Aparna.
Now, I work for
Philips Lighting.
And we're actually the largest
lighting company in the world.
And I think it's almost certain
that every single person
inside this room, has
actually experienced
some of our products.
Whether it's in our homes,
under the street lights, which
lights our roads,
all admiring one
of the thousands of monuments,
like San Francisco's Bay
Bridge, which we actually
do the lighting for.
Now Philips Lighting is
really driving for a change
in the lighting industry.
And that change is really
to tap into the value
that lighting being
ubiquitously all around us,
can potentially bring.
There is nowhere where
we work, travel, or enjoy
ourselves which is an underneath
multiple artificial light
points.
And we think that, by making
those light points more
intelligent, we can make the
world more personalizable,
easier to manage, and
easier to monitor.
Now our answer for
this transformation,
in the consumer space, is
my product, Phillip Hue,
which I been working on for
the last five or six years.
It is one of the most
popular smart home products.
And we really believe that by
making lighting in our homes
more connected, we
can really transform
what it does in our lives.
I believe that lighting can
be an alternative to having
a gadara home, by making it
seem like you're at home,
even when you're on vacation.
I believe that lighting can be
an alternative to your morning
cup of coffee.
By tapping into
the way our bodies
react to warm and cold light.
I believe that lighting is
an alternative to painting
your walls, by letting
you change the look
and feel of your rooms
multiple times a day,
to suit different activities.
I even think that,
in the future,
lighting will be an alternative
to surround sound speakers,
by having your lights
synchronized content on a TV
screen and bringing the
explosions, or the forest,
into your entire room in
synchronization with what's
going on the screen.
And we can do all of this
by making your lives more
comfortable and convenient.
There is untold potential
for smart lighting
to change how we live our lives.
Now, why do we need a cloud
solution to do all of this?
And actually, right from the
beginning of Philips Hue,
we designed a cloud
backend for our solution.
And we actually designed
it not as the primary way,
we focused as much as possible
to what actually happen locally
inside the home to keep
latency as low as possible,
but we always said we
need a cloud backend.
And we need it so that
we can let people control
and monitor their homes
when they're away.
We need it so that we can keep
all of our products up to date
the latest features
in security updates.
We need it so that we can
learn from our consumers
how people are actually using
this product so we can make it
better over time.
And we knew we needed it
to be able to integrate
with other cloud services
and platforms that
are out there to
realize new use cases.
Like, for example, with
if this then that, where
we can have your lights flash
when your favorite sports team
scores.
Now, we also have
some particular needs
that drove our choice in
design for Cloud solution.
One of the most
important things to us
is the incremental cost
per new home we serve.
And this is because
all the cloud services
to Philips Hue, we bundle
is a free service when
you buy your first new product.
That means the lifetime
cost to offer these services
towards that customer
have to be bundled
in the bill of materials
of that product.
So in order to keep our products
as affordable as possible--
we are obsessed with
making that cost
to offer this free service
as cheap as possible.
And it's really this incremental
cost for every new user.
Another thing which really
drove us, especially
at the beginning, was--
Philips Hue, we launched
it back in 2012,
was really a
new-to-world product.
And frankly, a lot
of people thought
we were a bit crazy
making a $60 lightbulb you
could connect to the internet.
Now, we believed that this
would become a huge thing,
but we didn't know
how fast it would.
We didn't know if
this is going to be
a very slow ramp
up, or something
that took off immediately.
And we really risked, in
building this cloud backend,
that we had a solution, which
either had the potential
to kill this small idea
early on by lumbering it
with expensive infrastructure,
and operations costs,
or, on the other side, that
couldn't actually keep up
if the market did explode.
That's one of the major
reasons we came to Google Cloud
when we were ready and built our
first infrastructure on Google
App Engine, because it let us
pay for what we needed, and let
us actually scale
when, luckily for us,
the market did explode
and continues to explode.
And we've actually had a very
surprisingly pleasant journey
in scaling our solution
multiple factors every year.
Another thing, we're
not a cloud company,
we're a lighting company.
What we do, and
what drives us, is
to offer the best possible
lighting use cases
and experiences to consumers.
And that's what I won't
spend my engineering money.
So I don't want to have to spend
all of my engineering money
on keeping infrastructure
up and running.
So I really wanted
a solution which
let me focus on actually
building our use cases out,
and not having to worry
about maintaining and running
infrastructure.
And finally, and this
one is actually a bit new
and wasn't something we had
in mind at the beginning,
is latency is super important.
When we first
designed all of this,
the idea was, OK,
you're controlling
your lights and outside of
home to update your schedules,
or check that you haven't
left the lights on.
It doesn't matter if it takes
a few seconds to do that.
But what's happening
more and more,
is other smart home products
are entering your home which
are cloud centric.
All of their logic intelligence,
APIs, sitting in the cloud.
And so we integrate
them also in the cloud.
So an integration, like what
we have with the Google Voice
Assistant, that actually
goes up to the Google
Cloud for the voice processing,
and then pokes our cloud APIs.
And this is something you're
doing inside your home.
And if your lights take more
than the second turn on,
that feels really slow.
So we have a new, renewed
push to actually get our cloud
latencies down as much as
possible, because it's actually
being used for real time
use cases inside the home.
Now, we have a very broad and
rich partnership with Google.
And it's one of the great
things about actually working
with Google.
We use a broad
variety of products.
We use a whole suite of products
from that cloud platform
together with Apigee,
to actually build up
cloud backend.
We build our own
Android app, and have
hundreds of other apps
built with our lighting APIs
running on Android
and Android Wear.
We were one of the very early
works with Nesse partners,
letting us offer use
cases to, for example,
reacts when a Nest Protect
Smoke alarm, detects smoke,
by setting your lights
to a dim red color, which
actually helps you see better
through white smoke conditions.
And we were also launch partners
for Google's new offerings
in the smartphone space, with
Google Home, Google Assistant,
and Google Wi-Fi, where we
also have great integrations.
So there's a lot of
touch points with Google.
And we really work
across the company
to achieve our mission of
letting people use lighting
in a richer way.
So what does this
actually look like?
So this is a snapshot, a
very cloud centric snapshot,
of how the new
architecture looks.
And we'll go through what
happens with a simple command.
Let's say you've taken
out your Android phone,
and you've asked Google
Assistant to turn off
your lights.
Something that happens
maybe not millions of times
a day, but lots of times a day.
What that will do, is that
will initiate a client
request using an API, to turn
off all lights inside the home.
That goes initially
towards Apigee,
which is our entry point towards
the cloud for clients, which
will check that that application
has the right permissions
to use APIs it's requesting,
and is given its quotas.
That then gets passed on
to a set of Kubernetes pods
that you call client Eastwood
These are the pods which handle
all of our clients requests,
they process that request,
and then they forward it on
towards the appropriate pod,
which is handling the connection
towards that particular home
that's being addressed.
And we do that forwarding
via Redis instance
that's running on
Compute Engine.
Now we actually have
two different ways
of interacting with
Hue homes, and that's
because we're in the
process of transitioning
towards a new, lower
latency solution.
So the legacy
mechanism, which will
stay relevant for a good
time yet, is GoldenGate.
And this you can
think of effectively
as a message queue, where all
messages for bridges to process
are stored, and it can be
pulled by bridges, when they're
triggered to do so, actually
fetch and processes messages.
The new solution that
we've come up with we
call Freddie Mercury.
And this actually maintains
permanent open WebSocket
connections towards every
home, concurrently, 24/7,
in the world.
And by doing this,
we are actually
able to push messages directly
into the homes with extremely
faster latency,
so we can actually
get much closer to real time
performance inside the home.
And we're rolling out
supports for this capability
towards bridges around
the world as we speak.
Now this Freddie Mercury
pod, actually, we
needed to develop
a new, custom auto
scaler to be able to get that
to work and scale reliably,
because we actually run
into limits of number
of open connections
on these pods
before we had any
memory or CPU limits.
So we have a custom
Autoscaler that is doing that.
Now, with either of
those pods, a message
will eventually arrive
into our bridge, which
is a central device we
have inside the home, that
manages the lighting
network inside the home.
That bridge will
process it, and then
initiate a Zogby
lightlink radio broadcast
inside the home, which we
picked up by all of the lights,
and then they will turn off.
And if we've done our
job right, and we're
using all new fancy
service, all of that
should happen in
less than a second.
So this is what it takes in
2017 to turn off a light bulb.
Next to that we have a
bunch of other services.
We have front-end, where
users can create and manage
accounts, monitor their homes,
which is actually built largely
on App Engine.
As well as a few of the things.
We do a lot of our
logging and analytics
and Datadog, which gives
us a really great overview
snapshot of everything
that's going on
within our infrastructure.
So this is more or less how
the Hue cloud is looking today.
So how is actually been
using Google Container
Engine in production?
I think the first
thing is, we've really
enjoyed using the technology.
It's really given us the
right balance between freedom
to actually optimize
and design our systems
for our particular needs that
we didn't have with App Engine.
But it's also not giving us
too much additional overhead
and burden in terms of
actually running the system,
and he's really given
us the confidence
to go all in with
small, micro-services
that we can run at scale,
allowing us to actually develop
and launch much more quickly
because we have a much
better separation of concerns.
So, all in all,
that's good stuff.
We're focusing on
features, we're
developing faster with
scaling, without having
to worry about infrastructure.
It hasn't been
without pain points.
It was quite some
work to actually make
the transition from App
Engine towards Kubernetes,
and some of the challenges
that we've had particularly
around the logging
infrastructure,
around GKE, where we had
quite some issues in terms
of getting reliable
logging out of the system
when pods were being
used intensively,
and we were developing.
So putting a lot of logging
in to understand what
was going on.
These things are now
largely resolved,
but it did make
some of the issues
that we faced early on a bit
more difficult to diagnose.
Another thing, something
that we're focusing on more,
is lower latency.
So we're looking at
how we can actually
have our infrastructure
replicated
in more places in the world,
just to get latencies down
so we don't have to cross
the Atlantic so often.
And that's something that we've
been reluctant to do up to now,
because it will increase the
amount of operational overhead
that we have, and my
developers say, no,
when I tell him about that.
But all in all, it's
been a great experience.
And we continue to enjoy Aparna
and the rest of the Kubernetes
team.
Do you want to come back up?
APARNA: Thank you,
George, that was great.
So, we have some features, in
our upcoming release in fact.
Philips is looking to
go to multi-regions
with their deployment, to lower
latencies in other regions
as well, and we
have some features
coming in our latest release
that should help with that.
And while specific
features are important
to specific customers,
I think one thing
that is important to all
customers is our velocity.
This chart is showing we
have had a consistent release
of Container Engine
and Kubernetes
every quarter over
the last year,
and we're going
to continue that.
So, the good news
is that if there
is a feature that
didn't get in this week,
it'll likely be
there in 12 weeks.
And you can contribute
to this project,
including contributing
to the code,
but also contributing use
cases, and what you'd like
to see in the features roadmap.
So, each release is not just
an effort of Google engineers,
but also our community
of users, and the broader
community of companies
that work on Kubernetes.
And overall, more than
442 years of effort
have gone into Kubernetes
and Container Engine.
So now, let's talk about
our upcoming release,
and what are the features that
we'd like to preview today.
As a reminder, this is roadmap,
so this is subject to change.
First and foremost, is scale.
Scale tends to be
important to a lot of you.
And we will be announcing,
Kubernetes will be announcing,
support for 5,000 node clusters
in the upcoming release
at the end of this month.
That means that a single
Kubernetes control
plane will be able to
control 5000 nodes, 5000 vms,
in the case of Container Engine,
and up to 30 pods per node.
So that gets you more than
100,000 pods per cluster.
That's a fairly large cluster.
You can put a lot of
services into that.
And along with that, we will
have sophisticated scheduling,
some of which I'll
talk about, and
sophisticated multi-tenancy
features, which
are on the roadmap as well.
Here's kind of the
history of scale.
You know, it was particularly
important to Pokemon Go
that we were working on
this when they came along.
And as you can see, Kubernetes
and Container Engine
started at a humble
100 pods per node,
and over the last two years
has now scaled up to 5,000.
Every time, the metric that
we've used to measure scale
is the same, which is that
99th percentile API latency is
less than one second, and the
99th percentile pod startup
time is less than five seconds.
And this has been tested
in our environment,
and verified for
5,000 node clusters.
And we look forward to
supporting production
applications on this.
So, you know, much
more practical,
scale is a good thing,
but you're not necessarily
going to manually scale
to a large number.
A lot of customers
use auto scaling,
and George mentioned that
they use auto scaling.
There are two types of
auto scaling in Kubernetes
and Container Engine, one is
horizontal pod auto scaling.
This has been
around for a while.
It's very easy to set up.
You can configure it for a
replica set or a deployment,
and you basically use
this command line.
You set a minimum and
a maximum, in terms
of the nodes that you want.
And currently, the target
that the system optimizes for
is CPU utilization.
This is not always
the thing that you
want to use that you
want to optimize for.
So one of the roadmap
items we're working on
is built in support
for custom metrics.
This is something, though,
that you can do today,
and as George
mentioned, they are
using a number of WebSocket
requests, or queue length,
as a custom metric to
feed into the auto scaler.
So that's something
that you can do,
it's not a feature yet, a
fully supported feature yet,
but many people do use it.
And that's one of the beautiful
things about Container Engine
and Kubernetes is the ways
that you can customize it.
The second feature
on auto scaling
is cluster auto scaling.
So, you have a cluster, you
can scale the number of pods
but what if a pod cannot be
scheduled because the cluster
is too full.
That's where a cluster
auto scaling comes in.
And we increase the size
of the pool by adding vms,
when necessary.
And when there's not enough
utilization on the vms,
so we decrease the skies.
So it's both scale
up, and scale down.
And again, that can be set
up with a simple command
specifying the minimum and
maximum nodes that you want.
I'm curious, how many of you are
using any of these auto scaling
features today?
That's great.
Yeah, I hear very positive
things about this.
Cluster auto-scaling
is beta, and we're
adding a lot more features to
support bigger clusters, so
expect that to go
GA in the next year.
The final point around
scaling is when you
want to go to multiple regions.
Currently, Kubernetes clusters
can span multiple zones,
and we'll talk
about how to set up
a multi-zone cluster
in the next portion,
but if you want to have a
presence in another region,
say in Europe and
in North America,
and you want to have a local
cluster another region, then
you go ahead and you set up
a cluster in that region.
With cluster federation, you
can manage those two clusters,
whether they are in
different regions or actually
in different clouds,
from a single API.
And that's done by setting
up a Federated control plane.
And these are some of the things
that the Federated control
plane offers.
It offers an API that's very
similar to the cluster API,
in fact it has all
of the same objects.
And in the upcoming release,
we will be announcing support
for deployments in
the federation API
as well as for DaemonSets.
So that means that
from one API endpoint,
you can deploy across
clusters in multiple regions,
or potentially multiple clouds.
And we continue to add
to that federation API.
The other things that
the control plane does
is check the health of the
cluster's, and also offers GEO
load balancing in GCP only.
So while scaling, and
auto-scaling, and federation
have been a big
part of what you've
come to expect from
Kubernetes, another thing that
has been top of mind
for many of our users,
is Stateful applications.
How can I run Stateful
applications in containers?
Should I run Stateful
That's a common question.
Dynamic storage provisioning is
going GA in the next release.
And we're going
to talk about how
to use Stateful applications
along with this.
A common misconception is
that containers are ephemeral,
and therefore, they're are only
good for stateless web serving
applications.
Kubernetes actually previsions
the storage automatically
for you, and with dynamic
storage provisioning,
it previsions the
storage dynamically when
a pod comes up, and it maintains
and persists that storage
until the application
needs that storage.
Let me talk a little bit more
about that provision storage.
One method is to specify,
in your pod spec,
that there's a
volume, and you'd like
to have that volume mounted.
And in this case, we say
by name what the volume is.
It's a GCE persistent disk,
its name is panda-disk,
and that's the type
of file system it has.
This is an OK methodology,
but it's static.
First of all, it assumes
that the storage, the volume,
already exists.
So someone has to pre-provision
that even though the pod hasn't
been provisioned yet,
that's a potential waste.
Secondly it's not portable.
So if you were to take those
pods back somewhere else,
and that place didn't have
as you see a persistent disk,
then this is kind of
useless, and it would break.
So the better way to do this
is through a persistent volume
claim.
A persistent volume claim
is basically a contract,
and that contract
doesn't name in the pod
spec a specific volume.
Instead, it has a claim name.
So this abstraction then
allows to Kubernetes
to bind the PVC claim to
the persistent volume.
And then when the pod comes
up and it requests the volume,
the volume can be created.
And this is an example
of what the PVC looks
like, the claim looks like.
In that claim you specify
what type of storage you want.
So in this case, we've said
it's a 100 gigs of stores that I
want, so the characteristics.
And then another abstraction,
which is the storage class.
The storage class can be
set by your cluster admin.
If you're in a company that
has a storage or cluster admin,
and they are choosing
what type of storage
should be available to
what type of applications,
they may create a storage
class, say a fast storage class
that refers to as SSDs.
Or a slow storage class that
refers to a specific type
of disk, in a specific cloud.
This separation of concerns
allows for portability,
and allows for policy
setting around storage.
But the real beauty of
this is, that it's actually
dynamically provisioned.
So, when you instantiate
or create your pod,
the PVC gets created,
and it's at that time
that Kubernetes will go ahead
and dynamically provision
the storage.
So it doesn't require that the
storage is pre-provisioned.
There's no wastage here.
Also, you would set the
policy in your default storage
provisioner, that when
the PVC goes away,
the storage goes away.
So it also cleans
up after itself.
That's one of the nice
things about dynamic storage
provisioning.
One thing I want to point out
is that in our next release,
while this is a nice set
of abstractions you've got,
storage provider, you've got
the user with the PVC claim,
and you've got a cluster admin.
Not everyone needs this
love of separation.
And Kubernetes does a nice job
in our next release of just
picking sane defaults for you.
So, pre-installed in the
next version of Kubernetes
and Container Engine, there are
these default storage classes.
In Google Cloud, it'll
be a GCE persistent disk,
in Amazon and OpenStack,
these will be the defaults.
And so you don't have to, in
fact, even say in your PVC
that there's a storage class.
This is the default class,
that will be assumed.
And when the PVC gets
provisioned, gets created,
the storage automatically
gets provisioned.
So I'd like to actually
demonstrate this.
I think the most power of
dynamic storage provisioning
comes in when you use it
with a Stateful application.
And I think, if
Kelsey is here, we
might actually have a
Stateful application
that can be used to demonstrate
dynamic storage provisioning.
KELSEY: You like
live demos, right?
All right, so I don't have
any slides for you guys.
So I apologize.
And we're going to talk about
this dynamic provisioning,
but provisioning storage without
an application to use it,
is kind of pointless.
So we're going to deploy
an app called Consul.
So if you've never
seen Consul, it's just
a key value store that
has built in replication,
and built in high
availability, using Wrapped,
and it also has a side
communication channel
using a swim protocol, so that
members can find each other,
even in the case of failures.
So the recommendation
for a Consul,
is that you run three nodes.
Now, the typical deployment is
each node has its own volume,
and is responsible
for its own data set,
and will replicate between
each of the members.
So we want to deploy
this and Kubernetes.
Now, if you're doing
this for the first time,
you don't want to learn a
particular cloud provider's
way of provisioning
storage, and making sure
that it's attached to the
proper node in the cluster.
So what we're going to
do is, work through this
and see how you do
it in Kubernetes.
So the first thing that
we're going to take a look at
is my current set up, and
my Google Cloud project.
I'm going to show you the
disks, a compute disk list.
So here you'll see that
I can't spell at all.
You just got to roll with it.
So here are the disk
that I currently have,
and those are attached
to my virtual machines.
So when you think
about this concept,
you already see it
for virtual machines.
When you click on a VM, no
one tells you to go provision
a disk first to attach that VM.
You assume that the
VM needs storage,
and that cloud provider
should create that for you.
We're taking that
and then extending it
to the application level.
So this is how I want
you to think about this
when you see this in action.
So now we need to describe
our StatefulSet So
what are we to do here,
there's a lot of content here,
but I'm going to highlight
the important parts.
So here, I'm saying
that I want three
copies of this application.
So, what will happen
here is Kubernetes
will create node zero,
node one, and node two.
And the next thing we need to do
is have storage assigned to us.
So we're going to scroll all
the way down to the bottom,
and we're going to
highlight this volume claim.
Now here, I am using a template.
Now the reason why I'm
using a template here,
I'm going to need
Kubernetes to stamp out
three versions of this.
I'm going to have a request,
based on the documentation,
I need about 10 gigs of
storage per application.
Consul isn't designed
to hold a lot of data,
it's just there for your
cluster configuration
and you're monitoring bits.
And also we don't really care
what the storage classes.
So if I was running this in
a different cloud provider,
ideally, the cluster
running in that provider,
would do the automated
storage provision for me.
So, what we want to do now is
submit this to our cluster.
Now we have some other
bits that are there,
but we won't go through those.
Things like configuration
files, and TLS certificates
so we can have a
secure console cluster,
but here want to
focus on the storage.
So, we're going to push this
to our Kubernetes master,
and while we do this,
let's look and see
what happens to the disk
while this is going.
So, we'll just
throw a watch there.
So, we see that we only
have three disks, so we'll
push this to Kubernetes now.
So kubectl create dash
f statefulsets console.
So this gets submitted to the
cluster, and you see instantly,
it goes out and
provisions the storage
based on the needs
of the operator.
So now at this point,
we can actually
look at a few pods
being created.
So, each of our applications
comes up one at a time.
And most of these
kind of applications
need to come up in
a specific order,
mainly because they
need to form a quorum,
and there's some
bootstrapping phase.
So node one is coming up.
That's going to be
scheduled by the scheduler
to a particular machine.
Once that decision
is made, that volume
will be then attached
to that machine
and injected into the
container at runtime.
Now, we'll do this a couple
more times until on behalf
of the entire cluster
up and running.
So let's give that a few
seconds and see where we are.
So we have two out of three.
Let's do a watch here.
All right, so this is creating.
Now as this creates, we're going
to actually go ahead and try
to communicate with our
cluster to see where we are.
So, here we are going to do,
is do a bit of port forwarding.
I don't want you guys
interacting with my clusters,
so we're going to do this
over a private channel.
So once I have this
connection in place,
I can start to interact
with this console cluster.
I can run things
like Consul Consul,
come on, Consul, members.
And you notice that there's
only one member listed here.
This is because they don't
know anything about each other.
They've all coming up with their
own independent stores volume,
and they do not have
the cluster membership
configuration stored yet.
We need to join the cluster.
So, what I'm going to do here,
you've got to raise your hand.
OK, yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you show the
storage that [INAUDIBLE]?
KELSEY: Ah, good question.
So in Kubernetes, we
talked about these volumes.
So, in Kubernetes, they're
called persistent volumes.
So if we say kubectl
get pv, for short,
we can actually see
those three volumes.
And you'll notice that they're
named some random name,
but they're also
attached to a claim.
So we list up the claim,
that PVC, what you'll see
is this convention.
You'll see the data
directories, the volume
that I'm specifying
inside of my manifest
and where I would
like it to be mounted,
and also the name of the
pod that it belongs to.
So StatefulSets gives yours
pods a consistent name,
consoles zero, console
one, console two.
Now this is cool if
you go up to five,
and you have to scale back down.
We can configure our storage
not to be deleted when our nodes
or pods go away, so that
way if we scale back up,
you're guaranteed to get the
same disk that you had before,
attached to the same name.
So you don't have to go around
and worry about that, OK?
So this is what's happening
underneath the scenes.
Everything is bound
to the right pods,
and that will stay
this way and we'll see
what happens if nodes go away.
All right, so given that,
what we want to do now
is see what we can do about
this cluster membership.
So we have council
members running,
but we only have one member.
So what we need to do
next, is form the cluster.
Then what we're going
to do is use a job here.
So since we have consistent
naming, using StatefulSets,
notice here that can
reference all of my members
by their DNS name.
Now, regardless of the IP
address, this will resolve.
So, I'm just going to use
the same console container,
it's going to run the console
a join command, using all three
members of that cluster.
So let's run this job
now and see what happens.
Kubectl create dash f jobs.
So we're looking at
our members here.
We'll run the job.
So this will go out and
communicate to all the members.
So if all of this is
working, we should
be able to see the
console UI here.
So let's check this out.
So we see all three members,
all help checks are passing.
Now why is this volume
claim necessary?
Why do we need this association
to this particular pod
name and its storage?
Well, what happens if one
of the pods goes away?
So here what I'm going to do
is delete one of our members.
Kubectl, delete pods, and
we'll give it this name.
Now notice the IP address
of this particular pod.
The IP address here is 0.11.
That's how all the other
members know it is as,
and that particular
member has inside
of its stores directory, the IP
addresses of its other peers.
So, if it goes
away, the only way
it's going to be able to send
signals back to its peers
that it has a different IP
address, if it comes back
with the exact same volume.
So it's critical that
we get the same volume
if something happens.
So we'll delete it here.
And at this point, the
heartbeats will timeout.
And this thing should
go from alive to failed.
And let's see if that happens.
So now it's failed.
Now, what we expect
Kubernetes to do
is automatically replace
this because we said
that we want three of these.
So if we look at pods, we see
that it's automatically been
recreated, just 15 seconds ago.
And now the storage is being
remounted to the new machine.
So what should happen
is, this machine
should come up, grab
its data volume,
have information about
the other members,
and start to broadcast signals
about its new IP address
if it has changed.
So it will give
us a few moments,
and see if we can actually
have our cluster come back
and have a full
quorum ready to go.
Well the demo guys are
like, I don't know.
Tick, tock tick.
Some people are on the
edge of their seats
like, it ain't gonna work.
I have confidence.
I think I do.
And it's back up and running.
That's how you use dynamic
provisioning with Kubernetes
1.6.
Thank you.
APARNA: Over to the slides.
Thank you, Kelsey.
So you saw dynamic
provisioning, didn't
need to have the storage
there beforehand,
and then the storage
persists afterwards.
The next feature, or the last
set of features, actually,
that we're going to preview
are related to scheduling.
There's a number of
advanced scheduling features
that are coming in
the next release,
and these should help
as you're provisioning
larger clusters and provisioning
clusters across zones.
So, first of all,
we do recommend
that clusters should be
provisioned across zones
because there is a
likelihood, or possibility,
of a single zone going down.
It's fairly easy to provision
a cluster across the zones.
Essentially, when you
create the cluster, or you
specify that you'd
like additional zones,
and it'll create nodes in
those additional zones.
And by default, the
scheduler will spread prods
across all the available
zones in a cluster.
That's nice.
You can also do it once
you've created the cluster,
and you want to edit it and add
zones, you can also do that.
That's nice, but there
are certain things
when you're working with a
cluster that spans zones,
that you might want to avoid.
And that's where some of
the custom of scheduling
and advance scheduling
techniques come in handy.
One of these techniques
is called node affinity.
Node affinity is where a
pod expresses a preference
for a certain node.
And it could be two types,
it could be a preference,
or it could be a requirement.
The node itself, the
characteristics of the node,
be specified in the pod spec.
So this is an
example of a pod spec
that is defining in an affinity.
It is a node affinity
that says that it prefers
a node that is in a
particular region,
in this case its us-central1-b.
And that's done through defining
an operator that operates
and connects a key to a value.
The key, in this case, is the
zone of the node, and the value
here that we're looking
for is us-central1-b,
and the operator is in, which
is I want the zone to be
in us-central1-b.
There are other operators, so
it's kind of like an equation
that you can set up, or
a regular expression.
Other operators that are
supported are in, or not in,
you could say not in this
zone, or such and such exists,
resource exists, or does not
exist, or is greater than,
or less than.
Those are the operators
that are supported.
So what will happen here is
that, since we've expressed
a preference and
not a requirement,
when the pod labeled App1, comes
in and has to be scheduled,
it will have a preference to
be scheduled in us-central1-b
and we have three nodes
in our multi-zone cluster
that are in us-central1-b,
so if there's
space available on
any of those, it'll
get preferentially
scheduled there.
It can still get scheduled
in the other zones
if there is not space
available, or you
can make this a hard
requirement if you
prefer you to use required.
So that's node affinity.
There are a number of built
keys for nodes already.
These are the built keys,
so it could be a zone,
it could be region, it
could be the host name.
So you could say, I
want a particular VM
and that's where it should be,
or a particular type of VM.
It could be a preemptible
VM, you could say,
I want these applications only
to be run on preemptible VMs,
and you specify that here,
and other things like
the type of disk, whether
it's SSD, what type of OS.
But the best thing is that
you can also write your own.
You can write your own,
essentially labels, on nodes
and then tell the
scheduler, I want
to schedule these pods on a
node that has these labels.
That's node affinity.
A related feature is
inter-pod affinity.
So now, you want to specify
where a particular application
should be scheduled, given
where a certain other service is
scheduled.
This can be very useful.
So again, we're talking
about multi-zone clusters
as an example.
If you have two
services that need
to communicate with
each other, say there's
an east-west pattern, and you
don't want those two services
to be scheduled in
different zones,
because then there's egress
charges associated with that.
Actually the latency is
very low in Google Cloud,
but there are egress charges
that you may want to avoid.
So for ensuring east-west
communication within zone,
you can set the
inter-pod affinity.
And this is an example of that.
So this is a replica set,
and there are three replicas,
and the name is App2.
And what we would like,
is for this App2 pod
to have an affinity to App1,
to wherever the zone is where
App1 is scheduled, we want App2
to be scheduled there as well.
And in this case, we're not
expressing a preference,
we're saying that it's required.
So we're say here, pod affinity,
required, and the operator
again, is in, and the value
is App1, and the key is zone.
So now we want App2 to be
co-scheduled in the same zone,
so that east-west communication
is less expensive.
There are other use
cases, of course.
It also works if you want to
co-locate north-south services,
and then there's
also anti-affinity.
So affinity is when you want to
pods to be scheduled together,
anti-affinity is when you
want to spread pods across,
so you want to spread your
services across your cluster.
This could be because you
will have some antagonist pods
that you want to keep
separated, or you
want sole tendency, or a
variety of other use cases.
So this is the other advanced
scheduling capability
that's going to be
available in this release.
And the third one,
which I think is perhaps
the most interesting
one, is this concept
of taints and tolerations.
And this is where
it's not really
a single pod, or a
single set of services,
that you want to set
rules on, but a whole
set of services that should
avoid a particular node.
Then what you do is
you taint the node.
You put a taint on
the node, and then you
put a toleration on
specific pods that
should tolerate that taint.
So an example is, here we
have a node that has two GPUs
whereas the other
nodes do not have GPUs.
So we can put a taint
on that node that says--
and that's how you do it,
kubectl, taint node, GPU true--
and so it prefers no schedule.
So do not schedule on this
one, because it is a GPU node
and it's maybe more
expensive, or is special.
And then that the
application, or the pod,
that actually requires GPUs,
you would put a toleration
on that one that
says the key is GPU,
and I have a
toleration for that.
So when that pod comes around,
it'll be scheduled to node one,
but every other pod will
avoid that tainted node.
This is very similar
to affinity in
that you can use required,
or preferred, and so forth.
But where this is really
interesting is in a feature
that we call
forgiveness, where you
put a taint on every node that
says you should stop and evict
all running pods,
in the case of say,
node becoming unresponsive,
or disk not being available,
in the case of a failure.
If the node fails, stop
the pods and evict them.
And then you can
put a toleration
on the pods
themselves that says,
how long should this pod remain
on this unresponsive node?
When should it get rescheduled?
So this is a really nice
feature that actually recently
had a very good use case, when
there was an S3 outage on AWS
last week, there's a company,
I think they're called--
I always forget their name--
I think they called Strype, or--
anyway.
There's a company that
was using this feature,
and when their nodes
became unresponsive,
their pods automatically
got rescheduled.
Because the disk wasn't
available on that node,
their pods had this toleration,
and after a certain amount
of time, they automatically got
scheduled to a node that did
have space available.
So those are some of
the advanced features
that are coming.
The last, and not least,
one is the ability
to set up a custom scheduler.
So you know this gives
you, all this gives
you, a lot of flexibility to
deploy the way you want to,
but you're not limited
by the default scheduler.
You can actually bring
in your own scheduler,
and extend Kubernetes
to use whatever
rules you want to have.
Let's see maybe Kelsey has
a demo left of the custom
scheduler as well.
KELSEY: Oh, yeah, I
have a custom scheduler.
All right, so our I kind of
talked about this ability
to give your nodes
attributes, ad-hoc attributes,
we call them annotations.
So on each node, if
you look at them,
if you were to list our
nodes in this cluster,
have three nodes in our cluster.
And what we can do, is
get a little bit more info
about them.
So if I say dash
0 equals yaml, we
get a bit more data
about these nodes.
And here, we can actually see
different attributes, labels,
annotations, and so forth.
Now, given that, we have
things like region and zone.
I want to build a
custom scheduler that
lets me choose the node
based on the cheapest price.
OK?
So all of these notes may
have different attributes,
but, hey, what I want to do, is
favor the cheapest nodes first,
before moving on
to the next node.
So one thing we need to do is
annotate our particular nodes.
So I have a little
tool, called annotator,
that just goes out
to the company's API,
and writes annotations on
them based on the price.
So we'll run this, and we see
that one of the nodes is $0.10
per hour, $0.80 per
hour, $0.40 per hour.
So ideally any workload
that I execute,
I want to run on ab, or 8b, 1b.
OK?
That's the goal.
So what is it required
to actually run
multiple schedulers
in Kubernetes?
Well you need to do a little
bit of things differently.
So here, I want to take
a deployment object,
so these deployments run
inside of Kubernetes,
and but default, the
default scheduler
pulls them, and runs
them inside your cluster.
Now, let's say you want to
use a different scheduler.
Here is the annotation
on my workload,
in this case of
deployment, and here I'm
using a custom
scheduler by name.
Now normally, this
would be default.
But when you get to this
level of Kubernetes,
you get to have a
scheduler named after you,
if you want that.
So this is the
Hightower scheduler.
And the Hightower scheduler
will pick nodes based on price.
So when this workload
gets executed,
it will be ignored by
the default scheduler.
That's the key here.
So these schedules get to run in
parallel inside of Kubernetes.
So I'm going to
run this workload,
and you notice here that
we do have CPU and memory
requirements.
So those two predicates can't
be ignored just for the cheapest
price, you need to
run on the node that
also fits our workload.
So what I'll do here, is deploy
this workload, Nginx custom.
So at this point, we now
have a pod of running.
And so we'll actually show
that here, kubectl, get pods.
And we'll throw a watch there.
So notice here that it's
sitting there pending.
How long will this pend?
This will pend
forever, actually.
Because there is no scheduler
running inside of the cluster
that knows what to do with this.
It's being ignored by
the default scheduler.
Only thing that we
have at this point
is our desire state that it
should be running somewhere,
but there is no scheduler
that's in charge of this.
So I wrote my own scheduler.
It's on my laptop, it's
also available on GitHub
if you want to
check out the code.
So here I'm going to
build a scheduler.
And I'm one to now have my
scheduler point at my cluster,
and schedule this
particular workload.
So here we'll just run it.
So we're starting our scheduler.
And notice here that we
scheduled this particular pod,
to this particular node.
And I want to remind you guys
of the price of these nodes
is to make sure that we
landed in the right place.
So we just do
annotator dash L again,
and we notice that this
was the cheapest price.
So this is where we
expected it to land,
and there we go,
it's up and running.
Now, if I were to
scale this out,
I expect the same behavior.
I prefer the cheapest node
until your workload no longer
fits before you spillover
to the next node.
So let's scale this up a little
bit to see how that works.
So what we'll do is
say kubectl scale,
deployments, and this is
going to be Nginx custom,
and then we're going
to give a replica set.
What number should we go up to?
AUDIENCE: 42.
KELSEY: 42?
Round it down to 40, divide by
4 is about 10, so we'll do that.
So we have 10 of these
things right now.
And we'll see what
our scheduler does,
so it's continuously
preferring the cheaper node.
Now eventually, that
node will no longer
be able to host our
workload, so we may have
to spill over to the next node.
Ideally, we want to spill
over to the cheaper node.
So there we go,
it's automatically
moved onto the cheapest node.
So my scheduler is
doing the right thing.
It's continuously
running and buying things
based on that last predicate
that I defined on my own.
So, the next question is, how do
you actually get the scheduler
to run inside of Kubernetes.
So I'm going to kill
it from our laptop,
and now we need to deploy
it to Kubernetes itself,
so of course, we need
to deployment object.
So here, we have a
scheduler object,
and it needs to run as a pod
itself inside of a cluster.
And if you've guessed
it, we're going
to use the default scheduler,
to schedule our scheduler,
so we can have parallel
schedulers, in our cluster.
OK?
So let's see if this works.
So we see we have some
custom workloads there,
so we'll say kubectl, create,
dash F, deployment scheduler.
And at this point,
our scheduler will
be scheduled by the
default scheduler,
and now, we have
parallel schedulers
running in Kubernetes.
Thank you.
APARNA: That's great.
Thank you, Kelsey.
So that concludes the
demos and the features
that we're going to announce.
There's a few more
features, obviously,
and there's a much
bigger roadmap.
There were other talks
at the conference
yesterday and today, that
talked about auto-upgrades
and auto-repair in
Container Engine.
That's something
that has launched
as beta as of this conference.
And then we are also
going to be introducing
RBAC, roll-based access
controls, as beta.
And network policy
is already beta.
And then Container
Runtime Interface
will be going beta as well
in the next release, which
allows you a choice of
different run times.
These are some of
the related sessions.
But what I'd like to do now,
is to open it up for Q&A,
and to invite George and
Kelsey to come up and join me
on stage for your questions.
KELSEY: Could we give
round of applause
for Aparna for our
awesome presentation?